salut tout le monde alors eh ben on est
de retour pour suivre les aventures
d'alix chine
donc nouvelle partie jouée à moscou en
1908 donc un an après la précédente est
en fait le même ton docte l'année
d'avant mais justement une année plus
tard hélas les blancs dont contraint un
joueur soviétique qui s'appelle parfenov
et donc et ben hilal et blanc les rôles
joués 4 et il va il va faire face à une
sorte de méthode relise précise qu'un
parent fondé en 1908 et away dans quelle
équipe considérée comme mauvaise herbe
on bosse ici si je trouve pas ça
terrible non plus enfin vers des six
alors quand même beaucoup plus logique
ouais il dit aussi spab ont affaibli les
cases noires notamment m6 dont qu'il
joue ou g5
alors bon je veux dire qu'un bon comme
telle et c3 c4 faut trois failles et
plein de mon coup mais pourquoi pas
theolia cette c3 qui des six mais il
fait pousser quatre vents il se
développe vers très classique
ouais peut-être que tous ces cas d'amd 2
c'était jouable h6 faut trois comme ça
vaut pas ce qui se passe c'est que les
noirs vont pas vraiment pouvoir rauque
et qu'on met la pression sur terre croix
catholique fourrage 6 donc
donc ouais c'est une option dam des deux
mais il a fait pousser 4 on voit
repoussé quatre pas mal aussi mais on
développe le fou après
c'est vrai qu'on sait pas exactement ce
qui fait sur cette diagonale qui est
déjà bouché choix des mets pour moin lé
kind s'avère assez simple ses jeunes
années un son jeu pour l'instant ce
qu'on voit ces développements et la
compil de l'euro adverse à 6 donc ouais
bon maryse esque d'am dam des deux est
là les noirs sortent un peu de du schéma
il aura sûrement dû jouer un coup comme
h6 jetons vont pas laisser les blancs
mettre eux mêmes le fou en page 6 ils
ont d'amd de l'idée clairement c'est
sûrement de faire flasher 6 et aussi
préparer grand rock ou même petit rock
ou moins à voir les toiles y est mais
qu'est ce qui se passe si les jockeys et
c6 donc mon faux âge 6 donc ça c'était
prévu prises dame prend est à quai nord
il a choisi de déloger l'adar hockey kg
8 donc il est reparti excellemment f4
évidemment d'alger cette saignée pas la
tour parce qu'il y avait des 9,6 cette
petite précision à propos d'un f4
peut-être dame e3 direct c'était pas mal
puisque absurde un f4 comme jeu dans la
partie il ya eu des 9,6 et a refusé
l'échangé des dames avec dame e3 donc
l'un dans l'autre il lâcha un tempo dams
est joué par les mains alors d'ailleurs
ici ali qui n'avait lui-même commenté
qui a éventuellement dame g7 serez
meilleurs et je pense qu'il a raison
l'idée c'est quoi c'est de laisser la
caisse de sa disponible aux cavaliers
pour se développer la dame bombal
contrôle un peu les cases noires là bas
et pourquoi pas faire fou 17 grand roque
ensuite ou quelque chose comme ça donc
ça avait l'air logique dams est moins
bien grand quitterait bien phu 17 est
donc allé eakin un peu con la partie
précédente en fait ainsi on voit les
schémas de son jeu ses développements
rapides et c'est ce qu'on dit de faire a
beaucoup de joueurs qui débutent pour
bien réussir leur d'ouverture tu
développes bits et vont se dire faire il
pas capable d'en faire autant touvre les
lignes d'un tel plan est donc choisi e 5
pour voir la position
alors après analyse il semblerait que
des 500 grands mieux mais c'est un peu
le même esprit c'est qu'on veut ouvrir
l'idée c'est quoi c'est que bon bien sûr
si on prend ça va beaucoup nous aider
mais sûrement ce que j'avais vu eric
hinske les blancs de le faire que les
noirs ou les faire caler au 5 mai après
prise prise ça qu'on a pu échanger ici
et en cas de refus prend prise dame
prend un style qui alliant des 5
donc c'est le genre position symétrique
mais où en fait tout est mieux pour les
blancs dire que si on compare le caïd et
5 par rapport auquel j 8
il n'y a pas photo il ya cahier central
mon client plus et direct une menace on
a déjà rauque et donc on va se mettre en
verre force verte ici les noirs bon bah
ils sont là voilà ils font rien avec le
roi le problème aussi c'est que si la ja
grand roque mon ya tout un foin géante
position c'est la dame s'engouffre là
bas et ça va être ma très vite parce que
la tour va fermer la porte ici et bal
adam va finir le boulot là-bas donc même
grand roque pour défendre c'est ça ne
serait pas vraiment possible et on sait
pas trop comment et d'en sortir parce
qu'il faut défendre ses sept gros qu'on
peut pas même si on fait des défenses un
peu artificielle au pire y aura f4 et la
position va s'ouvrir essaya très mal
donc c'était une très bonne manière de
jouer pour les blancs ceux des 5 mai au
sein et qu'en fait c'est un peu même
lors des des liquides en fait ils
espéraient vraisemblement de charges ou
des 5 est donc toujours pareil et à
lèvres en petites combines les prévu fou
prend des cinq puis on prend qu'avaient
les prends attaque la dame a taxé 7 dont
1 md 8 seule manière de tout défendre et
il avait vu qu'elle est si ce qui est
acquis c'est pas le truc c'est que
surprise prise
bon bah royer fuite va pas parce qu'il
ya des matches 6 est ok mais pas les
anges évident parce qu'il est d'alger
sept matches et s'il fait rue89 a
seulement fait un truc comme tour h 20
il faut aussi et en la soie dessins sont
faits d'armes g7 d'abord évoqué enfin
c'est juste un carnage quoi donc pas
possible
par contre lui éventuellement faut aussi
si si mais à ce moment l'emprunt md5
et puis ça se passe très très mal pour
les noirs on va récupérer des pièces de
moins et on fracasse le roi adverse
donc ouais ben voila c'était l'idée en
fait de deux dalles et qui n'entend de
cinq temps un peu ce piège mais
l'adversaire joue pas ma liste des fonds
du rif et cavaliers à 5
ok ok bien peu à la bande mais au moins
tu as que font ces quatre et ils
espèrent en gros calais keane va s'en
aller avec son fou pour pouvoir
éventuellement jouer jouer des 58 way
est donc allé keane fidèle à son style
choisi les lignes plus tendues possible
et bien fait déjà de remarquer que
beaucoup des possibles c'est déjà pas
simple fait fou des cinq donc les ce que
font leurs évidemment ça va pas prise
cavale et prend toujours pas les
histoires on attaque l'adav on va taxer
cette si la dame bouchons à pouvoir
prendre ici etc etc comme des huit
défend bien on prend des 6es tchèque il
ya du qui saute
bon c'est ça va pas du tout donc ouais
donc n 1 il conduire bien se défendre en
faux dessins qui fait grand cas ok puis
on prend des six il a pris du plomb
alors peut-être d'un me prendre pourquoi
pas il a pris l'option torah chemin
paraît y voilà il reprend le jeu simple
en fait ça qui est bien c'est à dire que
si elle a combiné est là mais sinon tout
est en place tout est selon les les
grands principes aux échecs
là c'est quoi ces cavaliers bien placé
vers le centre les foules bien
développer les tours au milieu machin
très logique tout ce qui se passe donc
la main sur il n'attend qu'une chose
c'est que son adversaire rendre dans ce
genre de finale parce qu'il était pas
mal en finale aussi en liquide et
l'aviation on est mieux meilleure
structure pion au tour active etc mais
non avec les dents il a fait qui allie
m6 mais là pas mal bon jeu ce n'est pas
intéressant unaf et b 4
donc évidemment on rend la position
compliquée il a reculé cavaliers prise
alors l'affection prend un mois est le
truc c'est que sur fou prend évidemment
le problème c'est qu'il ya des cinq donc
toujours les problèmes avec ce clouage
donc le plan des cinq est à bout faut
pas prendre ce qu'elle allait prendre
vous prend tout reprend juste pour
illustrer le plan inclurait donc max par
une pièce donc non et donc après des
cinq le chou le fou de repartir et on
sait pas trop parce que bon déjà on
attaque on attaque 6 mais aussi en
dessous la dame pour entrer là bas vers
à sept et on a déjà vu ses soucis donc
dur à dire quoi faire à kenner en fait
s'il faut 8 on peut simplement qui sait
le pion et déjà on va être quasiment
gagnant s'il faut 17 sarsat des
champions mais après un coup comme damas
est des problèmes arrivent dire que la
tour peut se coulisses et peut-être voir
dubé 5
ça vient un peu de tous les côtés voilà
voilà donc un peu pour ces raisons là
sont assez appris de b mais ça ne résout
pas tout et là elle est qu'ils jouent un
bon coup bon le même que celui qu'on
vient de voir en fait cédé 5 excellent
bah ouais ils vont entrer adam en jeu
pour tirer profit du roi adverse faible
et c'est un pattern qui reviendra très
souvent simple donc mais ferrat bessette
il tente de colmater d'un petit peu les
cases ici mais qui avait lié à 4 bien
joué on romaine charge pour pouvoir jeu
de mme bessis son prochain coup qu'elle
prend des 5 pour le service de qualité
puis on prend échec 3 à 8
ok alors voici vite cette fois semble
être une autre option mais a simplement
damas est suivi par kébé 6 après damas a
très bien joué aussi parce qu'on couche
ou un fou prend 1,4 pas possible de me
prendre un donc voilà on croit à 8 et
donc la petit chat comprend le pion par
échec trois là ont refait échecs dont
trois civils damas est ça marche
toujours roi 8 dames c est donc un peu
le même genre d'idée on veut faire qui
est b6 maths et oncle faut au passage dr
b 8 pour l'instant vont ils se battent
comme il peut pour défendre mais on va
manière ans farah attaque tous
retrouvent donc l'aider bien sûr c'est
d'amener la tour là-bas
pour promettre droit à 3 alors il a fait
d'amis huit bombes à l'idée c'est
d'aller bloquer un peu sur sur à 4 par
exemple s'ils ont fait tour à trois il
ya vous prend 1,4 mais bon bien sûr et
liquide
il voit clair il fait damas cinq échecs
preuve est cette dame échec donc
évidemment l'europe plus retourner dans
son abri là bas il ya dames la matte
donc il doit aller vers le milieu et
cette fois la tour en faire son boulot
ici là on peut pas couvrir
contrairement à 3 donc dans ces trois et
il ya eu abandon simplement parce
qu'après tout c'est six tours france et
6 3 17 d'amis ici c'est matt voilà donc
encore une bonne partie
voilà à mon sens kilim puis un petit
adversaires allaient qui n'a pour
l'instant
mais bon voilà toujours pareil victoire
bien construite il développait bien ces
pièces joue tranquille et dès qu'il faut
piquer être un peu affûté tactiquement
d'avoir des combines il est là voilà
allez on se retrouve encore pour deux
autres vidéos de belkin dans sa danse à
petit jeunesse a annoncé 18 ans quoi
ciao ciao